we do plan to brief the president
this week on it we have not done so yet
having sat in on briefings with him
about this
issue the questions he asks are how many
teachers are there
what specific steps can be done to
improve the processes of the timeline of
how
quickly kids get from um from shelter
facilities into homes
what's the logjam in the process why
didn't the president
make the trip to see the situation
himself and can we expect to visit to
the border for him in the coming weeks
ahead i don't have anything
anything on his schedule to read out he
felt it was most appropriate for
members of his policy staff to have
those conversations and do the first
trip
well the button administration is
scrambling to try to deal with this
issue on the border with illegal
immigrant
children unaccompanied minors showing up
in these border patrol facilities in
fact monday there were some
3 200 migrant children stuck in these
facilities
near the nearly half of those
over the three-day legal limit that the
customs and border protection
uh holding facilities can keep them for
so then they have to be sent someplace
else
inside the u.s according to the law
more than almost 200 of them are under
the age of 13 and just to give you a
perspective back february 21st
cbp held just nine unaccompanied
children
in those facilities so what about this
and where it's going let's bring in our
panel
fox news senior political analyst britt
hume mara liason national political
correspondent of national public radio
and byron york chief political
correspondent of the washington examiner
where do you see this this going and
what about the
administration's actions to deal with it
well it's and we're loads to call it a
crisis um we're calling it a challenge
maybe we can agree on a better term a
hell of a mess
uh it took him a while he went through
many fits and starts and problems
but donald trump and his administration
eventually got that border situation
down there under pretty good control to
accommodation of the wall
to uh the uh agreements with uh with the
neighboring countries to hold back some
of these immigrants and
have them apply for asylum from from
their countries
and so on uh and biden came in basically
blew it all up
and now we got a mess on our hands uh
entirely predictable consequence
of a kind of willy-nilly set of
executive actions undoing executive
actions and other measures taken by the
previous administration
uh it's clear to me now that that for
all political purposes
uh mr biden and his team now own this
problem
more than 1400 of these kids mara have
now been kept beyond the 72 hours that
they're supposed to be
you know put someplace else in uh and
they're now looking at facilities around
the country including fort lee virginia
yeah they've got to find a place to put
them they wanted to reunite them with
family members they wanted to see if
they could keep them in their home
countries and somehow dissuade them from
coming
but there are a lot of incentives to
come
the idea that the biden administration
is more welcoming to immigrants
the kind of traffickers who take money
from these
kids families and to to just get them to
the united states
so it's kind of it's a supply problem
and a demand problem and
biden has to figure out how to stop it
at its source he said that that's what
he was going to try to do
work with these countries give them aid
try to keep people from coming to the
border
but maura isn't president biden one of
the reasons that they're coming i mean
the message
absolutely they think he has a more
welcoming approach absolutely
and that's the tension for biden he
wanted to change
immigration policy wanted it to be more
welcoming
in certain cases he wants a path to
citizenship especially for the dreamers
and all that is like a magnet and at the
same time he doesn't want to have
a huge influx of people at the border
this is we're getting to this
time of year when border crossings are
higher springtime is when people come
so it's probably going to get worse
before it gets better
yeah i mean byron the trump
administration would point to saying
that no matter
spring summer winter or fall they had a
better handle on things as far as the
enforcement
and telling other countries in latin
america not to send these
kids or anybody else here are some
senators on the issue of the border
by the administration essentially saying
if you're willing to make that long
dangerous journey
if you're willing to put your life at
risk your kid's life at risk we'll put
you in their rolling back policies to
allow the border to be overrun
the asylum claims are going to go
through the roof and by the summer
you're going to have a million people
coming into this country
legally all because the liberals can do
it we certainly do not want to see
divided families that occurred under the
prior administration
but we need to have a sensible policy to
protect people who are at risk
but also to make sure we have secure
borders
byron thoughts well
we know that joe biden was worried about
this
during the transition he talked about
changing
president trump's policies too quickly
and ending up with two million
people on the border he still might get
there
the the message of the administration
has been
if you come you can stay and and all of
this talk we're hearing there was this
fact-finding trip
um uh that top officials went to the
border
over the weekend and actually you heard
the the vice president's chief of
staff julissa renoso say that they
haven't talked to the president about it
yet they hope to
do it sometime but all of the policy
none of it is devoted to
limiting the number of people who cross
into the united states
it's accommodating the number of people
who cross into the united states more
quickly and more efficiency
and i do think uh going from david
spence report tonight about fort lee in
virginia
if you do see the administration
starting to fly people
all around the country to house them it
will be harder for them to
claim that it's just a challenge and not
a crisis
yeah bret i mean clearly in the way
republicans are talking about this
this is going to shape up to be a big
issue ahead of 2022.
i want to turn for a second and talk
about the covet relief that passed the
senate
50 to 49 over the weekend
and the prospects of what that means for
any other bipartisan legislation this
obviously was not that
well as it's been pointed out by a
number of others the republicans went
down to the white house a group of them
and tried to begin negotiations with the
body administration with
their proposal for a 600 billion dollar
package and nothing ever came of that
meeting the body administration simply
ignored what they'd said and went ahead
and
rammed through because they could uh the
bill that they've now passed which is
now being passed brett
at a time when all the signals are now
suggesting that the economy is poised
for a rapid recovery bill or no bill
and we've got some staggering sum of
tens of billions of dollars
uh from the last round of relief not yet
spent
so this you know this may be a triumph
and they were all cheering it on the
senate floor when it passed on saturday
night
um but my guess is this uh this may not
age well
yeah mara it's expected obviously to
pass the house uh with those numbers
even though it's a tight majority over
there
there are some things in this bill that
i don't think people who were polled
about it
knew were in there
yeah i mean a bill this size we're going
to find out a lot about what's in it but
also what i think you're going to see
the biden administration do
something that the that they think the
obama administration didn't do enough of
is take a real victory lap try to
educate people about what
the government just gave them remember
people got the money from the obama
stimulus but they never knew they did
because it was in their paychecks
instead of as a check sent to their
house
and this is a huge there's a lot of
social policy
in this bill the increase of the child
tax credit which by some accounts will
cut child
poverty in half or by 40 percent that's
really big
i've also heard although i don't know
the details that there were actually
some things for specific republicans in
this bill
um you know maybe for more bipartisan
approach yeah
even though they didn't vote for it and
um i think the big question for me is
this was a totally partisan party line
vote
when the biden turns his attention to
the next big project which is the big
build back better infrastructure bill
will he include republicans in the
ground floor
on the discussions of how to create the
package not at the end after he has his
plan and then the republicans say well
here's ours
but if he does truly have a bipartisan
process on some of that
we will see it's obviously the taxpayers
with
footing the bill for all of this stand
by